they just started going and we started
shooting and it went down
an officer-involved shooting is caught
on body camera video after a suspect
takes police on a high-speed chase
Bobby Crawford
it all unfolded on June 21st in Las
Cruces New Mexico multiple departments
responded to the chase including local
and State Police
[Music]
officials say when they approach the
suspect 47-year-old Bobby Crawford he
sped off leading them on a high-speed
chase body camera video captures an
officer explaining what happened
so plus we're coming
off turn it on to a quarter I see you
right at the gas club or some gas or
something yeah yeah
um so at that point in time you get back
together
passes by since the bells inside the
driver's side at that moment as soon as
we pulled up there we're planning we're
just identified to see how many people
are outside the gas station because they
said it was going to be 1080 with the 45
caliber guns
um and just based off our knowledge will
be a full violation officials say
Crawford had warrants out for his arrest
and failed to stop for state police
eventually First Responders say Crawford
barricaded himself into his SUV and
fired at least one round at officers
body camera video shows what led up to
the shooting when an officer opens fire
video then shows First Responders on the
scene grabbed Shields and arm themselves
wow
[Music]
thank you let's chill hey I got a shield
chill Shield
[Music]
s
right now
goodbye
police
accident vehicle right now officers can
be heard explaining what happened before
they call for Crawford to come out with
his hands up they started shooting and
he went down
is everybody okay here
yeah
is everybody good here show me your
hands
I don't know
show me your heads
SUV we need to get a heads up and come
out with your hands up and have to do it
now
any occupant in the car
put your hands up and come out with your
hands up and have to do it now guess
[Music]
sir yeah I'm good
that's what I got over here
whoever's shot and as you take charge of
everybody back here please you want me
to stand by back there when one of the
officers involved in the shooting leaves
the immediate area of the scene a fellow
officer checks to make sure he wasn't
hit
you're all right though did someone
check you already we're getting there no
I was behind my door I was buying my
door after I got it
I just seen them I've seen him coming
out of this
yeah did you guys shut it yeah
then the officer explains what led up to
the shooting I don't know how I ended up
three I was like number oh the third one
dude
I passed them well they're in the field
and he came behind me so I just jumped
in behind dollars right here there was a
guy there was a guy in Black that took
off running there was
an ass I was an ass this dude
Butler was he by himself
because I seen a guy I grind a black
shirt took off running when we're coming
over here off that little ranch area
yeah so I don't know if he was involved
but he watched us go by so I don't I
don't know if he was just watching it
happen
decide
and uh and at that point uh yeah I
didn't see anybody else
foreign
shots fired call is made
shots fired
let's go
another another shot another shot shot
yeah he's going for the gun
shut up
the officer then continues to break down
what led up to the shooting
out of the shot of the truck
I shot through my windshield
don't tell me no more straight up APD
action right there
[Music]
okay
and approach
my rifle jam though
after your first
two three rounds
at least he didn't hit him grab it and
ejected it re-racked and got the
recovery outside try reloading it and I
look
through it downstairs
at that point you have another defend on
you just get behind cover and get your
they didn't use it though they did them
they did they did the loop around at
that house or back to the fence you know
I passed the house and he came behind me
so the oil was in front you can call her
baby and I got third
then for the first time officials
mention the suspect's name
what's his name
First Responders then speak with a woman
identifying as Crawford's wife who
claims she's experienced a similar
situation in the past
somebody tell me what they're doing
they're just deploying uh Vapors trying
to get them out of the car I was in
charge the lieutenant
SWAT team
can you call him he's in Florence Oregon
training right now
no we have we have our SWAT team as well
Commander dealing with that just let you
know okay I'll let you know when it's
gonna go off
it's gonna go off right now three two
one
depends what kind
of house we usually have three but we
had a three bangers back at home
the bank should always try to alert him
I'll please
you gotta think of it from our
perspective
we got him out the last time I get that
you got a restaurant
everybody was there let me talk to him
on the phone to get him out he started
crying he put up his hand out the window
and he got out of the truck oh it works
later the woman can be heard yelling at
officers
you shouldn't have ran from the cops
either
with his barricade in the house
eventually First Responders get word
that Crawford is out of the vehicle
we just started calling stuff out
luckily added secondary just calling all
every location and then at a certain
point in the desert a partner says
Arkansas and I think he shot it it's
just now like I didn't see it dude
so I had a surfboard
clear and they're still trying to clean
the car though
so one of your guys called it out that
you heard the shop yeah
so we were here initially I was going to
try and I got close enough but I'm
suppression unit they was following me
now on Mark he said it's very good he's
not behind us we can't do it yet and
then after falling desert for a while
um
[Music]
we just we pulled the side let him take
it we take primary hopped and right
behind him secondary just kept hollowing
and then and you guys you guys got no
freaking password we have like six units
as soon as soon as the call came out at
least five or six minutes jumped on it
never coming from the west side
oh yeah
I was like all the rest of the roads
were training over here at one of the
middle schools I think you guys passed
by
shooter training
it's not gonna get away this time he's
been very lucky again he's been getting
he's like a ghost yeah
has been he doesn't stay in here very
long and seen uh it was a good phone so
you guys freaking roll in bro I was like
in the desert we're just waiting for him
we're just waiting to pop out and just
Crawford now faces multiple charges
including two counts of attempted first
degree murder and aggravated assault
upon a peace officer right now he's
scheduled for a jury trial in February
of next year reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie